ebox is a balloon born telescope it's
designed to make baby pictures of the
universe there's a light that was
emitted when the universe was very very
young before the formation of galaxies
and clusters and stars and planets and
that light carries the imprint it's like
a photograph of what the universe looked
like when it was 380,000 years old it
also carries an imprint potentially of
what the universe was like when it was
much much less than one second old
so the first thing that we need to do as
scientists is figure out everything
that's happened up until this point in
the history of the universe this tells
us so much important information about
the fundamental aspects of our universe
how big is it how old is it how
energetic is it what's it made of is it
going to live forever is it going to die
furthermore if we can really accurately
measure everything that has happened in
the universe up until today we actually
have a really good chance of knowing in
predicting what will happen to the
universe in the future the aim of the
project is to measure what's called the
primordial gravitational wave background
this is a signal that we believe was
generated the moments just after the Big
Bang unfortunately this signal is
extremely faint it's very difficult to
see so in order for us experimenters to
see or measure this signal we need to
create experiments that have
unprecedented and sensitivity to this
polarization we use extremely tiny
technology that needs to be made in a
micro fabrication facility to probe the
largest scales of the universe so we use
sensors that exists on the micron scale
one millionth of a meter to probe the
universe which exists on the billions
and billions of meters scale
so the light will come in from the sky
just like a telescope that you would
think of an optical telescope hits that
first big mirror then it hits the second
mirror and then it comes and is directed
into the space that's now occupied by
this barbell looking thing and that is
actually just a weight that's that is a
weight that is now in place of the
camera there's going to be a very large
camera that holds cryogenically cooled
detectors they're cooled down to very
very low temperatures to reduce the
intrinsic noise so that the very very
faint signal from the sky is the thing
that we see instead of noise coming from
our detectors there's a very specific
process that we have developed here UC
Berkeley in order to fabricate a very
specific type of detector called a
spiderweb transition and sensor
bolometer these detectors are fabricated
by taking a silicon wafer depositing a
very thin film about one micron thick of
silicon nitride and then on top of that
we use several layers of metal which
becomes a sensor of the detector and
then on top of that we add a gold layer
which then is patterned into the shape
of the spiderweb which will actually
sense the radiation or absorb the
radiation and so the photons which have
this signal imprinted on them will come
through the optics of our experiment and
then fall on to these spiderweb
structures and those spiderweb
structures absorb the radiation and that
radiation will then cause the sensor to
heat up or cool down depending on how
much radiation there is and those
temperature readings will then
correspond to amounts of polarizations
in different parts of the sky and as we
measure those different polarization
levels in the different parts of the sky
we're actually measuring this faint
pattern that we originally sought out to
measure this signal would actually be
the oldest signal that scientists have
ever measured
and through measurement of this signal
we can actually measure the energy
scales at which the universe was created
and this is one huge step towards
achieving the holy grail of physics a
grand unified theory as we will actually
have an experimental verification of
just how much energy the universe had
when it came into existence
you